neutrinos sie wohl mysteriösesten
teilchen in unserem universum
sie kommen am häufigsten vor aber wir
wissen kaum etwas über sie das kriegen
experiment in karlsruhe will jetzt sind
das geheimnis der neutrinos kommen mit
der genauesten waage der welt und dem
reinsten vakuum auf der erde so wird das
experiment gerne bezeichnet sollen die
neutrinos gewogen werden und vielleicht
erfahren wir dabei auch warum es keinen
nichts gibt und wieso ist materie und
kaum anti materie im all gibt ihr habt
euch das thema whatsapp gewünscht und
vielen dank dafür hat sie bekommen also
bei klick zum science and fiction
heute übrigens vom cern in genf
elektrisch neutral leicht und das
häufigste elementarteilchen überhaupt
dass galaxien formt und hinter der
bewegung im universum steckt doch wie
schwer sind sie rund 200 forscherinnen
und forscher sind beteiligt und dem
rätsel auf der spur erstens was will man
mit dem experiment erreichen neutrinos
wurden lange zeit auch als geister
teilchen bezeichnet denn sie
interagieren nicht mit gewöhnlicher
materie oder kaum sie rasen statt dessen
einfach durch sie hindurch durch
menschen hände bäume oder auch sterne
und planeten lange ging man also davon
aus dass sie keine masse besitzen
doch mittlerweile weiß man dass sie wohl
einfach sehr sehr leicht sind eventuell
sind sie sogar zu leicht um sie derzeit
überhaupt messen zu können erst vor drei
jahren entdeckte aber macdonald bei
direkten messungen der neutrino
oszillationen dass sie überhaupt eine
masse haben
dafür bekam er einen nobelpreis seitdem
sind forschungsteams den neutrino massen
dicht auf der spur
wenn es überhaupt gelingt diese zu
bestimmen dann mit katrin am karlsruher
institut für technologie kit
denn die messe empfindlichkeit von
katrin ist 100 mal empfindlicher als die
bisherige anlagen langfristig wollen
forschungsteams durch das verständnis
dieser elementarteilchen aber vor allem
die grundfragen des universums verstehen
warum gibt es etwas und warum gibt es
nicht einfach nichts konkret also warum
es beim urknall ein ungleichgewicht
zwischen materie und antimaterie
entstanden
zweitens wie genau funktioniert das
katrin experiment zurück zum experiment
selbst tatsächlich werden gar nicht die
neutrinos gemessen wie auch wenn sie
doch wie geistreichen durch alles
hindurch gelangen gemessen werden ihre
begleiter elektronen nämlich die
entstehen beim zerfall der atome des
wasserstoff isotops tritium zu helium
der ganze prozess wird beta zerfall
genannt und tritium steckt auch im namen
von katrin dass es nämlich die abkürzung
für karlsruhe tritium neutrino
experiment konkret ist das experiment
den nackten neutrinos auf der spur also
den neutrinos die bei dem beta zerfall
von der freigesetzte energie abbekommen
haben denn da man weiß wie hoch die
ursprünglich freigesetzte energie war
kann man von der bewegungsenergie des
elektrons eine absolute mesz bestimmung
masse bestimmung der neutrinos vornehmen
die einheit dafür mehr mgv also milli
elektronenvolt kurios wenn man bedenkt
dass die masse anderer teilchen in
einheiten angegeben werden die viele
milliarden mal größer sind und so
funktioniert der 70 meter lange
versuchsaufbau konkret tritium ein
radioaktives wasserstoffatom tritt in
ein vakuum ohr bei seinem zerfall
wandelt sich ein neutron in ein elektron
ein proton und ein neutrino wie gesagt
wird dann die bewegungsenergie des
elektrons gemessen dafür müssen andere
elektronen herausgefiltert werden
dieses geschieht durch ein magnetfeld
dass die teilchen durch eine
unglaubliche 23 meter lange vakuumkammer
führt und je ist es wirklich ein
irrsinniges vakuum ja und nur die
stärksten und schnellsten die zusammen
mit dem nackten neutrino entstanden sind
die schaffen es bis auf die andere seite
zum detektor am ende des versuchs
drittens mit welchen ergebnissen rechnet
man der größte erfolg für die
forscherinnen und forscher wäre es mit
hilfe von katrin die genaue masse der
neutrinos zu bestimmen dafür müsste sie
mehr als 200 msv betragen denn so viel
gibt katrin her
bisher liegt die obergrenze bei etwa 2
elektronenvolt und so viel steht fest so
viel wiegen neutrinos also noch mal
nicht ein kleiner trostpreis wäre es
aber auch mit katrin diese grenze zu
verschieben also die angabe einer neuen
obergrenze zu machen
die größte sensation aber wäre es wenn
katrin frühere modelle komplett wieder
legen würde diese hatten aus beobachtung
der alh hintergrundstrahlung berechnet
dass die masse der neutrinos nicht über
einem elektronenvolt liegen können
andere ergebnisse würden also die säulen
des standardmodells der kosmologie von
grund auf erschüttert viertens wie lange
hat katrin zeit 60 millionen euro und 17
jahre arbeit stecken in katrin und
forschungsteams setzen große hoffnungen
in die anlage
falls bis zum jahr 2023 noch immer keine
absolute massen bestimmung möglich sein
sollte ist ein
update von katrin geplant dann würden
messungen bis 100 msv möglich werden
doch mehr geht definitiv nicht dazu
schreibt das wissenschaftsmagazin
science katrin könnte die letzte
hoffnung der physiker sein
die neutrino masse zu messen zumindest
ohne eine revolutionäre neue technik
wenn ihr keine videos dazu zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann
endet mich bei whatsapp dann umgeht er
die kaputte abo boxer auf youtube und
verpasst kein video mehr
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
noch vor allen anderen vom neuesten
video täglich garantiert einfach hier
draufklicken und am besten auch meinen
schwesterkanal klicks zum social media
abonnieren tag gibt es das neue social
media welt dafür hier klicken
aber natürlich nicht die genau die
glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter
mit dafür auch draufklicken neues
teilchen entdeckt bis dann bleibt